so I'm going to talk about some new some
ongoing work that I'm doing with my
students touch once iran iraq is on the
title will be a bit different strange
but probably you understand it in the
end so it's about emergency barriers in
for dynamic MST for with what case was
kids up their time so before i start
anything let me just get all this done
at once and this doesn't work okay sorry
i just use my youth my hand so some all
the notations that I guess all of us
probably are familiar with anywhere so
ms t is minimum spanning tree st is
spanning tree and is usually number of
nodes in the graph m number of edges and
in most of the talk poly log and will be
hidden most of the time just because i'm
lazy to write it down and so when they
say linear time for example it will be
mean near linear time and the last thing
that probably a little bit less you show
is the other if it will differ it will
be the cut between s and V minus is I
will come back to this notation again
when we need them but otherwise you know
it's good to see them all of them wants
now I have all notations so I'll just
start with the summary so this the
motivation of the whole world is to work
on this problem call worst case dynamic
MST minimal spanning tree it's to me
it's a pretty hard problem so and I
guess people have a few questions about
this problem for example can you do it
in poly logarithmic time and if you'd
understand at this point don't worry
i'll come back to everything can you do
it a bit better than root in time or
what techniques do you need to do this
or can you prove a low bow and against
the last part is the most relevant part
to the workshop so
unfortunately there are a lot of
barriers before we can actually solve
this problem so for example worst case
of dynamic connectivity with kids
dynamic spanning tree and so on so the
main barrier that i will look at that i
will focus on and in this hug is called
emergency cut side oracle and don't be
surprised if you don't know about it
because it's not it is recent it's quite
new and the nice thing about this
article is actually is a barrier to
quite a few other things so one of them
is this worst case of dynamic spanning
tree which is you know a barrier to the
MST yourself and the other problem is
the minimum cut problem the worst case
dynamic minimum cut so that's why I kind
of like this barrier and so the main
point of the talk is what can be learned
from this barrier so just just one one
one thing that maybe I should warn you
right now so in the rest of the talk it
will be a positive result for algorithm
people which means is negative for
people proving low valves so but its
algorithm talk but you know there's a
point of view of low bar over 2 so first
of all if you want to know whether you
can solve the problem in poly locker is
make time for the dynamic MST or not
which i think is the big goal that we
want to achieve one message that I want
to say is you better break this n to the
one-third bow for this problem call
emergency cut size first and then on the
other hand if you want to prove low
about maybe you can you can just look at
this emergency cut size model and prove
a lot of n to the one-third in this
model instead of going to the dynamic
setting
and probably the weaker question is can
you actually just break this nth root n
time so it's kind of the best outcome
right now for dynamic MST and the answer
is maybe but then if you really want to
do it from from what we learn from here
is that maybe you need this you need to
know this technique of colleague you
know flow techniques better in the diner
dynamic setting and the bad news is it's
not really understood in the dynamic
setting much so probably we have to if
you really want to prove up about maybe
you have to understand this more and
again if you don't understand anything
I'm saying hopefully i will try to make
you understand me the rest of the talk
so so the part 1 i will just introduce
the problem dynamic mft and the notion
of worst-case update I'm so so our
bodies dynamic graph so dynamic craft
probably most of you already know you
have this graph with n nodes and the
thing is graph could change over time so
you start with this graph and at some
point you probably delete some edge here
and you could add some ish later on so
add H could be added and deleted and the
goal oh yes and then you you probably
delete some more the goal is to maintain
some information about the graph so
that's the general the general question
and okay what do we want to actually
maintain in this talk so where there
would be three problems so the problem
the first problem is called dynamic
connectivity and this is a simplified
version of it so what you want to know
is whether the graph is connected or not
so you start from this graph which is
connected so your algorithm should say
that the graph is connected and at some
point some edge got deleted and then
your algorithm should say that is not
connected anymore and then it got
connected again so your algorithm should
say that a harder problem is spanning
tree so instead of just maintaining
whether the graph is connected or not
you want to maintain the spanning tree
or Spanish
so you could start with this graph and
with this spanning tree the blue edges
and then you delete something so the
spanning tree has to change and if you
delete more probably the spanning tree
has to change again so you keep help you
have to keep you know maintaining the
spanning tree and the last one which you
know is the big boss that I am trying to
attack is minimum spanning tree so now
the graph has weight you have weights on
edges like this one and the goal is to
maintain minimum spanning tree which in
this graph looks like this so if you
look at the way this is the smallest one
and then if you delete something then
you have to find your spanning tree and
again if you delete another edge you
have to find a spanning tree so that's
the three basic problem that we will
talk about most of the time in this talk
so just to come back to the picture
again we have these three problems
connectivity which is you can show that
it's easiest and you have dynamic
spanning tree and enemies MST which is
the hardest and kind of the main goal
that we want to attack the next thing is
I have to define the notion of time
complexity so that will be two notion
amortized and were skills so let me
start with the worst-case running time
complexity so it is it's just you know
the most simple thing that you can
imagine of you delete something just one
ish and you want to know how much time
you need to recover the information that
you want to maintain for example if you
want to maintain minimum spanning tree
it calls the time from when you delete
this edge in this graph and then until
when you get the new edge which is this
edge in the span in the minimum spanning
tree so this is one time and then you
delete something again you delete this
guy then you get this guy and then you
get another time T and this is called
worst-case at their time and these
convoys cares because we want to
contrast it with something called
amortized which if you are not familiar
with all these just remember that it's
easier to achieve you
really have to understand the notation
but if just a quick reminder if you just
want to know is to say that you have a
motorized aunty if after k updates the
time that you need in total is Katie so
you just come from the beginning every
time here it's not like you start here
okay so what is known about this problem
connectivity spanning tree and minimum
spanning tree so first let's start with
the easy case Emmett I for any time and
this is actually pretty much done a long
time ago if you what I mean by that is
that you can have political to me about
highs at the time for all these three
problems and this is due to Monica and
singer valeri King and Nico toe loop and
a few others so there's not much to do
for amortize up their time how about
worst-case up their time so the
situation is quite different so what one
thing we know which is pretty recent and
pretty exciting I think is that the
easiest guy dynamic connectivity again
worst case after time now he's done you
can do it in poly logarithmic time
workers for this problem and this is due
to valor reaching and co-authors a few
years ago at the main techniques that
are pretty nice is this one of them is
sketching technique
so what how about other problems so for
other problems actually the best
algorithm goes back I don't know 30
years ago it's due to frederickson and
Epstein and a few others so the running
time is root n so it work for mft does
it work for spanning tree and
connectivity to so that's still the base
we know for this problem so and and so
this msg is basically what again what I
I want to you know try to to say
something about it and so a few
questions about this dynamic span MST
problem you know one big problem is can
you get pulley local with poly locker at
any time which means that you probably
solve the whole thing and some people
believe that it's possible because
usually all these three questions go
together if you solve one usually later
on you manage to solve others so
probably it's possible but right now the
even smaller question is can you just
break root and time of Federation from
30 years ago and it's not just for
dynamic MST but even for the spanning
tree problem and of course if you want
to break this you have to know what
techniques we need to solve the problem
and I guess one product one technique
that probably we need if the sketching
techniques which were used for the
connectivity problem by King like a pro
at all and of course can we prove low
bass instead if we don't think that this
is possible
and in this talk this is the main court
of tal I want to try to answer these
questions by studying one barrier in
this area in you know among many
barriers it is called the barrier in the
setting called emergency and we don't
have a complete answer but hopefully we
have something so the emergency setting
that prop we will look at basically two
problems so one of them is emergency
cuts I Oracle which is the main the main
problem that we will look at and the
other one which is a little bit easier
is emergency MST so what is now I'm sure
many of you don't know what what does it
mean by emergency setting so now we also
i will talk about that a little bit so
first of all let me introduce the notion
of emergency setting and the problem I
would use this emergency MST problem as
an example and by the way the name of
emergency came from paper by petrescu at
me Kyoto loop is called I think in his
paper is called emergency planning but I
just want to make it shorter so it's
become emergency and if you have written
a paper about dynamic algorithms before
I think probably you have look at this
model before but it's just that you
didn't call it this way so the main
feature of the model is that you will
have only one batch of updates instead
of you know a sequence of updates so so
to be more precise so you will have
three things in the algorithm the first
phase you just have a graph G and you
have to pre-process it so you have this
pre-processing and then there is some
updates so you have some updates you to
the graph meaning you have this bunch of
edge deletions and insertion but the
important thing is is come in bash so
you see all the updates at the same time
not you know one by one and then the
last part now you are asked some query
if there's any query
after you know after the graph is
changed so here's an example emergency
minimum spanning tree problem so you
given this graph in the beginning and
then I just give you a batch of two
updates which is just to deletions which
I just say I plead elite these two edges
and now your job is to find a new MST so
there's no query it at this point you
just you know once you see the updates
you have to recover the new mft as fast
as possible so I hope that that is not
not too hard to see what it means and
probably now you have you probably ask
why you have to look at this emergency
setting so I want to argue that it's
important from both proving Lobos and
upper bowels so from proving Apple
boughs so we will see this vaccine that
if you have fast dynamic algorithm then
you will have fast emergency algorithm
to and so emergency problem is kind of a
problem that you have to broke foot
brake first before you can break really
you know the dynamic problem and along
the way maybe you will learn some new
techniques that you can use to really
break the big boss from the low bow
perspective the emergency setting is you
know is just three phases it's closer to
the to the static setting so if you are
hoping to use some you know some
conjectures that you have seen in the
workshop before like that or three some
or other problems in the static setting
probably it's easier to look at this
model first because it just has a few
faces it's closer to the static setting
and this kind of of Lobos was actually
proved proven before in I just give one
example so in pataskala multi-phase
problem you just have three phases and
from there he reduced from three son to
this multi-phase problem so hopefully
you know if you don't have so many faces
maybe it's easier to reduce from the
static problems
so okay so that's all the motivation so
again I just want to make thing more
concrete so let's look at emergency MSD
again so we again we view it as a
barrier to the dynamic MST problem and
why is it a barrier and it is because
the following fact so if you want to
obtain n to the route you know root n to
the one half minus epsilon worst-case at
their time for dynamic MST so something
better than the current base upper bow
then you actually have to obtain the
emergency MST algorithm with the
following running time so in the update
you have a graph with M edges the time
that you need will have to be better
than M root n so m to the one half minus
epsilon and in the update step you have
this list of update let's say you have
you this so the time that you need will
have to be a little bit better than root
n / one update in you so it has to be
you times n to the one half minus
epsilon why can't you use the amortized
algorithm because the amortized
algorithm oh so you already see the
proof why where you can prove this ok
you cannot use Emma tight because Emma
sighs always start from the beginning
you know when you have the running time
and we want to now emergency how to
separate the running time into two parts
and you know if you use amortize this
part usually will be blown up a lot it
will be through up ok
but anyway I would just give a child
proof here anyway so you just so if you
want to do this you just pretend that
you know okay the most important part is
this update part how can you handle
updates so just pretend that you delete
one inch at a time so you have seen the
example before where I start from this
graph and I delete two edges here so and
then I get this new result so instead of
you know you met instead of having to
updates you just imagine that you have
some some one more one update in between
and then this update and so to handle
this update you just run the dynamic
algorithm and then for another one you
run another part another dynamic
algorithm and at the update and so you
just need you know update x times the
number of updates and if you understand
this part you probably thought you can
see that you can replace this part you
know this running time with anything so
if I want to get fully logarithmic time
for the MST I have to get you know
almost linear time for preprocessing and
the size for the update this has to be
linear in the in the size of the updates
so you can replace by any number
so I would say that this is one of them
you know obvious barrier for for the
dynamic mft if you have to solve this
problem first emergency MST and I think
it is a good time to mention another
barrier which is called emergency
connectivity just to put you know
everything in the picture so this
actually was study in 2007 by Pat Roscoe
and genre and so they kind of broke that
already but with with some condition but
later on in the world of cap run at all
they kind of break it I think I
completely accept that the algorithm is
randomized so that's obvious barrier is
gone and it's probably a good time to
mention one minor result of ours as well
so the minor is I'll say that for
emergency MST you can actually do do
things pretty fast so in the
pre-processing you just need om time and
in the update you just need all of you
time so almost linear everywhere and the
technique is just you know we just start
from the sketching technique that we
that Cap'n that I'll use and then do
some some data structure called fully
persistent so it's not much so but
that's a bad news for I think for mobile
oeuvre because we want to have some
barrier that we can say something but
now this guy is gone
so we need some new barrier and I think
the next kind of not very obvious but
the next natural barrier is this problem
called emergency cut sides Oracle which
is going to be what I will focus on next
so what is emergency cuts eyes Oracle so
I have before I defy emergency cuts eyes
Oracle I should defy static cuts eyes or
offers so this is you just think of it
as static data structure so you have you
just imagined you have two phase of
algorithm in the first phase do you have
a graph G and you can pre process it and
then there's no change you just get a
query Aparri is you have s as a
parameter and f is a sub you know set of
nodes and what you have to output is
Delta the size of the other is which is
the set you know the size of the cut so
it's defined here Delta s is a set of
edges between s and V minus s and so
this is the picture so if i have this
graph if f is here then i have to answer
for because i have these four edges
crossing between s and D minus s so
that's that's what we want to do for the
test articles you want to quickly answer
you know the number of edges between s
and V minus s now in the emergency
setting you just have one more one more
step so is three fiercest now so the
additional step is you can update the
graph with this update you and so now
you have a new graph G prime and when
you have a query as you have to again
output the size of the cut in this new
graph G prime instead of the original
graph so that gives that is the only
difference and this is an example again
so you have G and then you probably
delete some edges in G so you get G
prime and when you query now you have to
answer to instead of four
so this problem is pretty new but it's
not completely new so actually a few
things are known so first of all we can
get some approximation algorithm and
it's pretty fast and this is again in
the paper of capital net all that solve
that connectivity problem so they can
pre process the graph oh and I should
note that it actually worked in the
dynamic setting not just emergency
setting so it can process the grass in
linear time and update the graph again
in linear time in the number of updates
and then when you have the query you can
answer that which you know with just
size of the query which you have to to
pay anyway so these are the best running
time you can get possible the only
problem is that is approximation follow
exact algorithm so i will say for
approximation okay this is pretty much
done because you cannot improve this how
about exact algorithm so you can show
that actually there's a low bow if you
add if you want to assume something so
the low bar will be F plus the size of
the output that you want to answer so
you should compare to this upper bar so
you cannot actually get this you need
this extra term Delta s and this is for
the static for the query time even for
the static Oracle actually so and even
if you have a lot a lot of
pre-processing time these two happen you
still need is nice native lower bowel
okay so we have lower bowel that says
that you cannot achieve exactly the same
thing as exact algorithm how about upper
bow and the problem is is not known much
even for the static article but the
interesting thing is exactly here so if
you to end this you know if you
understand my claim is that
understanding exact algorithm for
emergency cut size oracle is a barrier
to worst-case dynamic MST so and what I
mean exactly is this so here's the lemma
if you want to solve dynamic MST with
this running time n to the one half
minutes Exxon then we must obtain
emergency cut size oracle with the
following running time so again for the
pre-processing the best possible is
linear time or M so but now if you are
talking about entered one half minutes
it's done here then you are allowed to
have n to the one half minutes epsilon
here and also here for the update time
and for the query time you have you
allowed to have this extra Delta s times
n to the one half minutes Exxon over
here so if you want to get something
better than good and here you better
have these running time first for the
emergency cut sides Oracle and again if
you want to even go further to go to
Polly log n then you have to improve all
these two pulley log into so I guess how
much you can go here kind of tells you
how far you can go with the dynamic MST
problem
and okay this is just a quick proof why
why this is the case why dilemma is true
so you so right now you just want to
solve the emergency cut size oracle you
start with a graph and you just give
arbitrary weights to the graph so let's
say you start with this graph you have
these ways here and then we when we have
updates in the update fails we just use
dynamic mft to solve to to just maintain
maintained the MST and so the the thing
that I want to explain that I think left
a list radio is how to get the query
okay so pre-processing and updates is
pretty much trivial because you know you
just run the run the MST algorithm so
how can you answer the query so the
first step is to explore our mfc edges
that is incident us so let's look at
example here so you have this graph
these come from you know the first two
phases you already delete one edge let's
say here this is the msg that you have
the blue edges and now you have this
query of s you want to you know answer
Delta s so the first thing you do is to
look at all the edges incident us to eat
two nodes in s which are this one this
one and this one three three edges and
the next step is you delete edges that
cross the cut meaning these two edges so
you will end up with this picture where
these two edges are deleted and then you
do the same thing again so you get some
replacement edge to get the new MST so
let's say these two red edge red edges
are in the MST so this guy is in the cut
again so you delete him again and so you
have this graph and at this point you
don't have anything left in the cut so
basically the graph is disconnected so
that part you are ready to answer and
you answer will be the number of times
you have deleted an edge because you
always delete edges
across the cut and that is three times
in this example so the running time
should be for the query time should be
obvious I hope so you probably need this
much time to just read the query and
also to explore edges inside s which is
in the MST and then you have to do a few
number of deletions and for that you
have to pay the time for the update time
for the MST but the deletion is you
answer delta s so that's why the total
query time will be S Plus Delta s times
MST up their time which if you want to
get better and root and then this will
be Delta s tab times something better
than good in
so with that lemma that we let me show
you just limit this lemma 1 right so for
this why were you why did you need to
have the minimum spanning tree rather
than any spanning tree good point any
spanning tree will be fine to you just I
just want to focus on this so that's why
it's a barrier to spending three two or
only what you just have to be careful on
one thing it is that when you you know
that there are different types of
adversary and this adversary that are
deleting edges they see the spanning
tree before they make deletions but you
write is spanning tree worth to
okay so so and so did that that one
means by being a barrier now so if you
want to get better than root and here
you have to get better than root in
across all three parts here by the proof
that I just show and another nice thing
that I like about this barrier is that
it's actually a barrier to as i said
before dynamic spanning three two if you
just you know do the same thing as
before do you think the same proves you
can show that is this one works too and
you can use another question which is a
dynamic minimum cut problem to solve to
solve the problem the parameter will be
a bit different but you can show that
it's a barrier to so that's that's all
we want to answer we want to know
whether you can how far you can go with
this can you can you replace this red
thing by poly log for example and our
results is kind of you know something in
the middle is break what we ask a little
bit but not all the way through poly log
so we show that there is an emergency
cut size oracle such that the
pre-processing takes this n to the one
half plus little or one time and little
one highest kind of is written here log
log divided by square root log an update
time again you have this extra into
one-third plus 320 one and also for the
query time you have n to one-third plus
little 01 and there are some site
results as well so first of all as i
said even the static setting is not at
that so far we are not aware of you know
anyone saying about anything about
static oracle so what we found is you
can get everything you know the best
possible for statics kiss so or in time
for people setting or you time for up
their time and this s plus theta is for
query and it's actually a important
component to solve the problem
the emergency problem as well and
actually I have to note one thing so
actually we can output Delta s to not
touch the size of the data is so in the
end then you know because we have the
low bow anyway that you need this much
time so which one oh sorry you right i
did you forget about this for static
setting there is no update it's a typo
yes and we can output delta s 2 and you
know later on i actually will kind of
emphasize this fact we actually need to
list all the edges crossing the cut and
sometimes we call this emergency cut set
instead of emergency cut size it starts
to say that you can actually output
edges in the cut
and as I said before it is a barrier to
the cut mean cut problem too and you
need different parameter for that but we
can break that one too but it's not a
focus of this town
so um so I have stated the main results
and I think people will interpret it in
different ways old I would just say how
interpreted as I said in the beginning
so the first question you probably asked
is can you get fully long time for
dynamic msg problem in the worst case
and so for me I think you since we have
this entered one third right now so my
reaction will be you better break this
into the one-third bow for the emergency
cuts eyes first before you can get put
login for MST and if you want to prove
low bow instead if you want to say that
this is not possible probably you can
show n to the one-third lower bar in
this model image for this problem and
again I think it's probably easier
because it's closer to the static
setting the other probably less
ambitious question is try to just break
the current baseball which is root in
and my reaction will be probably maybe
but then i would guess that you probably
have to understand the flow techniques
better in the dynamic setting and why do
I say this the reason is the way we
solve the problem so now i will show you
a little bit of how how we kind of
approach the problem so this is our
Oracle in the end and to go here you
just you know derive quite a few flow
techniques up here is the max max flow
approximate max net flow which we have
seen progress in the last few years and
then you use that with some cut matching
games to get some some spices cut
algorithm a variant of spices card
called balance passes cut and from there
we develop something called high
expansion decomposition and or the other
route we have this three cuts pacifier
which were developed again recently by
reggae and his co-authors and from there
we get this static cuts eyes Oracle and
Static a size Oracle is part of our
see oracle is one of the important
subroutine and of course you need this
linear sketches with visual used in
previous paper by capital narrow for the
dynamic connectivity problem so my
interpretation here is if you want to
make this one or you know getting
something about dynamic is probably you
have to understand better how all these
play a role in the dynamic setting for
otherwise you have to find some other
way to to solve the emergency cut size
problem so um so Michael I think I have
about 10 10 minutes left so the goal
right now is just to give you kind of a
sketch of what happening in this picture
and that's all five okay thanks fine
okay anyway just so so it's going to be
a sketch of the algorithm and again as I
said before our algorithm actually
output the cut so don't be confused if
you see that we are actually i'll put
the cut and i guess i will just have
time to explain this part and again
we're very loved roughly so i will just
make things a bit simpler and assume
something so i will assume that we have
exactly and deletions and no insertions
during the update so you have a graph
and then you make any updates which is
divisions and then you do something you
do the query so we have basically two
cases the easy case which I'm not going
to go into details so much is when the
query size is less than n to the two
third in this case is easy because you
can just use previous techniques that we
know before which is some sketches and
some random partitioning technique so
it's pretty simple so I'm going to skip
the details here
so and the main focus will be how to
deal with this hard case when the query
is pretty rough Peter pretty large and
for here we need something called high
expansion decomposition so what is high
expansion decomposition I have to defy
something first so if you have a set of
a node then expansion of the set of node
which is denoted by CS will be the size
of the cut you know from s to s bar /
minimum between s and V minus s so if
you imagine that s is smaller than n
divided by 2 then it's just you know the
number of edges / num of nodes and the
expansion of the graph is just the
minimum of that so minimum among all the
s in the in in the graph and see of that
okay so that's the usual definition oh
and this is example so if three here and
is to hear so now what is high expansion
decomposition it states the following
you given a parameter alpha and we can
do the following in almost linear time
so there any time that you have is n
plus 1 to the dto one so you can
partition the edges in g into two parts
s0 so the part one is h0 and the other
part will have this h1 h2 and so on so
in h0 the nice thing about h0 is its
parts so you have these many edges alpha
times n2 and hospital one again alpha is
parameter that you have and for the rest
you will have high expansion so the
expansion will be at least alpha okay
yes I expansion on the set of nodes of
the server Jason or something they're
not necessarily going to so I'm
expansion by this definition so for it
for every set of nodes is this it's a oh
it's just in that graph you're talking
about this sub graph H I
so H I might only contain a subset of
the nodes as well right it might contain
a subset of the nodes and sub set of
edges right yes
okay and okay we we need this test in
the beginning in the pre-processing you
just run this expansion decomposition
and then to add in the rest you just
handle all these h0 h1 h2 and so on
separately so how can you handle the
dispatch part the h0 you just run the
static algorithm you know in the
pre-processing you do nothing for this
s0 and because the crowd is sparse when
there are deletions you just run static
algorithm and usually have so many edges
there so you will be fine and then when
you have query you just use this static
algorithm to solve to answer the query
so let's and now we quickly now so now
for each high expansion ish I what do
you do so there is this easy case where
you know you have this sub graph edge we
should have high expansion and this is
the query if the intersection is not so
large then you can just use the easy
case that we had before that denote the
query is small then you just run these
sketches that we had in the previous
part that I say that easy so the
interesting part is this part when the
intersection is high but then when the
intersection is high then we know that
the answer will be large because the
graph has high expansion so we know that
this Delta H I and intersection between
this is at least 2 N and since we delete
all the n end edges so we we have a lot
of edges left that we should output so
what we will do is again we use static
Oracle in the pre-processing and in
during update we do nothing and then for
query we just used this article to
answer the query ok so of course the
Oracle my output some you know some
deleted edges that you already deleted
but it's not much you have n deletions
but you have answer of 2n so that's a
lot to answer and so you can charge the
cost to your answer so that's a more
details but i think i will skip that and
i will just show you the picture that i
show in the beginning
again so the whole talk is about this
this guy emergency cut size Oracle and
again it depends on what you interpret
but i will say that it's interesting
object that we should study first if we
want to attack dynamic minimum spanning
tree it depends on whether you want to
prove low bow or up about but i think is
interesting interesting from both point
of view so and just a few open problems
so can you prove low bow in this for
this problem for example and that will
be great because if you can prove some
lobe out here you will rule out the
possibility to get dynamic spanning tree
and MST and also mean cut at the same
time or if you can prove up about you
know improve what we had from entered
winter to Polly log in and I think oh
and can you extend the result to dynamic
setting ok so thank you
so your address was fighting boys right
yes there are many cases and the part of
this hidden is this decompose hi
expansion decomposition as well goodbye
yeah I mean this is already simplified I
think ok I think this decomposition part
is the most complicated part and I think
it has to be there that does not believe
so but probably other other parts that
you knew you know unique case analysis
probably you can avoid but it's not
clear you know if you probably can do
something better for this if you know
better how to use this high expansion
decomposition i will give that probably
you can avoid something apart the right
now just that we have limited way to use
it